let's do some examples creating picture
and bar graphs
so it says mr smith assigned a special
project about the ocean to the students
in his earth science class
to find out if students who spend more
time on their projects got better grades
he asked the students how much time they
spent completing their projects
create a bar graph to show how much time
each student spent completing the ocean
project
so james spent 36 minutes
so i wanna i'm gonna click here and i'm
going to move this
i'm going to move this up to 36
eg
ig spent 54 minutes so i'm going to move
this up
to 54 minutes
and then min lee spent 36 minutes
so i'm going to move minli up to
36 minutes
then simone spent 30 minutes so i'm
going to move simone up to 30. and then
karen spent 12 minutes so i'll move
karen up to 12. and there you go i've
constructed the bar graph
let's do a couple more of these
all right so on thursday ming went to
see a loud and exciting performance by
the dinosaur orchestra create a bar
graph to show how many of each type of
dinosaur were in the dinosaur orchestra
so i guess there were 42 stegosauruses
i don't know if that's the plural for
stegosaurus so they're 42 stegosauruses
63 raptors so let me move the raptor up
to 63. 35 triceratops
and then
you had 49 tyrannosaurus
49 of these so fairly straightforward
so let's let's do a couple more of these
all right so now it tells us rose's
flower shop makes bouquets for special
occasions
each bouquet comes with a different
number of flowers create a picture graph
to show the number of flowers in each
bouquet so this is kind of like a bar
graph but instead we're going to use
pictures and each picture shows a
certain number so in this case a picture
of a flower represents three flowers
so the mother's day bouquet
has 21 flowers
so 21 flowers now you might want you
might be tempted to put 21 pictures of
flowers here but you have to remember
each of these flowers represent three
flowers so one way to think about you
could count by threes 3
21 so that over here this right over
here would represent 21 flowers and you
notice i just made
i just made seven of this picture and
that makes sense because seven of these
pictures and each of these pictures
represent three flowers seven times
three is twenty-one the mother's the
mother's day bouquet has 21 flowers in
it
all right the anniversary bouquet has 27
flowers
so 3 6 9 12 15 18 21 24
27 i have nine flowers here nine times
three is 27.
the birthday bouquet has 18.
so 3 6 9 9
12 15 18. and i just made six pictures
here because each of them represent
three flowers six times three is
eighteen and then finally the
congratulations bouquet has twelve
flowers in it
three six
9
and
12.
there you go i think we're done
i think
i think we're done let's do one more of
these
all right
barry b and his b friends loved
pollinate flowers they created a chart
and a picture graph to show how many
flowers each of them pollinated today
use the information in the chart to
answer the question about the picture
graph
so it says so on the pictograph each
flower equals blank flowers or each
picture of a flower i should say equals
a blank number of flowers
so it says barry
pollinated 27 these are impressive bees
that they sit there making charts barry
made
barry pollinated 27 flowers
and they only drew three pictures here
so these three flower pictures must
represent 27. so the way that they would
represent 27 is if each of these
represent 9 because we'd have 9 18
27
so each of these must be 9 flowers but
let's see if that works
so for bumbly 63
so let's see 9 18 27
27 36 45 54
63 yep it looks like it works out betty
is one two three four five six
six six times nine is 54 and that is the
number of flowers she pollinated
birdie one two three four five if each
of those pictures represent nine then
this would be five times nine is
forty-five and that is the number of
flowers birdie
had actually pollinated